a hospital is a place that's full of
emotion this is where the sick are cured
children are brought into the world and
other people leave it so when a place
like this is sold off to a large
corporation that wants to change how its
run a lot of people often get pretty
upset this is focalin clown it's obvious
that for all those concerns the process
of making the hospital we've taken over
into what it's going to be in five or
six years will be painful just a change
is always painful Eden foreign delish
Matt's office this is all Schneider
chairman of the fresenius board he's
well known for the high rates of return
that he demands from his hospitals
Schneider expects profits of up to
fifteen percent but how much pressure on
return of investment can patients bear
yet skint allowing patients to sense
financial pressure would be the fastest
way to damage a hospital's reputation
curiously even otherwise critical media
reports agree with us here I remember a
headline that said the only things we
handle with kid gloves are our patient
signs you must be in bacta parking
tickets interest for semillas is run
from this office headquarters in bad
homburg the company employs 200,000
people around the world fresenius has an
annual turnover of 20 billion euros and
old schneider wants to expand the
business further but is he set on
achieving growth at any price buxom Eden
Christ as his growth regardless of costs
never makes good business sense teats it
always has to go hand-in-hand with other
goals frequently after a successful
takeover we're asked what we're planning
to buy next but at that time speculating
about our next transaction is not at all
important for the company because that's
you open oya concerts you own sword
survives mosquitoes at that particular
moment the only thing that counts is the
proper integration into the wider
company
of what we've just acquired and making
sure that the goals we set with that
acquisition are fulfilled is it soon
foot would not oh it food be it the
corporation has just pulled off a coup
its subsidiary helios acquired 40
clinic's patients there could soon enjoy
technological advances in treatment like
the heart valve operation shown here
specialists from three other clinics
have traveled here to assist but for the
staff it will mean greater efficiency
achieved through new routines and
structures to cut cause some services
might be outsourced the boss himself
sometimes joins the daily rounds to get
some insight into the lives of his key
workers you know I facio behind hook
tough one I'm really impressed by how
hard nursing staff work in hospitals
traditionally medicine has always been
more focused on the contribution of
doctors the importance of other medical
staff for the overall success of a
hospital from the point of view of
patients is often underestimated
individual interest the company does
more than just run hospitals it's also a
global market leader in dialysis and
other medical technology when you're
preparing medical products hygiene is
the top priority if just one container
is not sterile it could cause a
catastrophe in this business Trust is
everything the plant in friedberg is
completely automated it needs no staff
at all the bosses say that's the only
way the corporation can keep up with the
international competition
fresenius products are shipped to more
than 100 countries the company wants to
expand particularly into emerging
economies that initiative will have to
come from old Schneider when the
company's chief executive got the top
job he was just 37 years old to spot
omelets easily and it was a really big
step in this role you're the person who
has the last word it's do you have to
make decisions that are not possible to
make in a group at the end of the day
you make them alone and you alone are
responsible for their results so far the
system headed by wolf Schneider has
taken fresenius to the very top of its
field and the company's journey is far
from over
you